[Musik]
teile dollar handelt von zwei jungen
frauen leben in berlin wie einer will in
der sicherheitsbranche was werden also
bei der polizei oder bei der bewachung
von gebäuden oder was auch immer und die
andere die am rand von dem was ein
bisschen das gegenteil von sicherheit
ist also in verhältnissen wird zwischen
dachboden und wohnwagen und die wildere
bringt er weniger werden bei dass die
weniger wilde eigentlich viel wilder ist
das aber nicht nur gute seiten hat
[Musik]
der schauplatz ist ein ganz besonderes
berlin es ist ein bisschen das berlin
dass man vielleicht kennt von den
platten von grossstadtgeflüster
grossstadtgeflüster in elektro pop trio
aus berlin
die machen was die platten wie ein reh
plastikkuh zähler abgestürzt berlin und
eben ein reh also diese mischung aus
niedlich und was war das denn gerade
zeichnet auch den film aus
[Musik]
was man hier gar nicht krieg sind
figuren an denen man sich sozusagen
moralisch aufrichten oder die man
moralisch verabscheuen kann die beiden
frauen sind dazu wissen zu kompliziert
aber muss ja auch nicht immer seien im
kino kann man ja dann wieder in der
schule machen allerschlimmste sind wie
immer bei film wo viel los ist
die dialoge die kampfszenen jedoch die
dialoge ich weiß es nicht die
kampfszenen sind choreografiert und
geprobt die dialoge nicht könnt auch
umgekehrt seien auch das weiß ich mich
und da sieht das nicht weiß hat mir sehr
gut gefallen hätte bestehen einen film
unter anderem darum warum wir uns
eigentlich irgendwas gefallen lassen
also warum sonst mit leuten
identifizieren die uns was tun warum wir
läuten gehorchen die uns was zu tun an
drohen ganz ganz toll sind alle alle
alle schauspielerinnen und schauspieler
vor allen dingen erhoben falls tiger und
maria dragus als vanilla wie sie wählen
sollten den film auf jeden fall eine
leute die unbedingt mal nach berlin
wollten weil vielleicht wäre es dann
nicht mehr und alle die eventuell aus
berlin kommen sind und natürlich erst
recht alle leute die einfach in berlin
wohnen und darüber gar nicht mehr
nachdenken weil das kann sehr
anstrengend sein über so etwas
nachzudenken und es ist viel schöner
sich anzugucken
[Musik]